you know over here do you like your
breakfast cereal mm-hmm well then how
would you feel if we took it away and
improve it for we've made Cheerios twice
as cheery rific give me back my damn
serious we've added more whole-grain OT
goodness
Tod goodness give me back my Cheerios or
we've created Cheerios too wouldn't you
like to know it as twice the amount of
fiber I don't care and it is triple the
amount of extra wholesome I don't give a
shit give me back my Cheerios right now
but it also has 40 times the amount of
monosaturated carbohydrates I don't
think you understand I don't care but it
can even reduce cholesterol now look
there's something you don't understand
here
I've been eating Cheerios ever since I
was a little kid I was raised on them I
would eat them every morning for every
day of my life
they hold certain sentimental value for
me I don't want that taken away please
please give me back my Cheerios ah but
don't you know that Cheerios too has 50
times the amount of vitamins a b c a d
through z iron thiamine riboflavin
niacin folic acid phosphorous magnesium
zinc copper lime nickel mints platinum
gold silver and monosodium tripe a OPEC
tape poly an fama can expect rate high
falutin iron chloride number 60 I want
my Cheerios asshole oh I think you've
underestimated my powers all right bitch
come on oh so you want to fight the
invisible man behind the camera
get some calm well I'm right behind you
aha see Cheerios reduce cholesterol also
it spread about heart healthy
I got your soluble fiber goodness
Cheerios - toasted whole-grain Oh what
the hell am I kidding we just put that
too on the damn box
just the same you poor fella Jesus
Cheerios to the cereal with a punch